welcome everyone to the next installment
of beckmann culture webinar series
my name is dr chad schwartz i'm an
application scientist for beckmann
coulter here in indianapolis indiana
i'm honored to host this next session
with our speaker dr jeffrey fagan
at the national institute of standards
and technology
on his presentation
over the analytical ultracentrifugation
of carbon nanotubes
dr fagan received his bachelor of
science in chemical engineering from
johns hopkins in 2000
he went on to carnegie mellon and did a
phd in chemical engineering and received
that in 2005.
since 2005
he has done a postdoc and is now a
product leader for the particle tubes
and colloids project
at the national institute of standards
and technology
a couple things to note
during this presentation
we ask
all listeners to post presentation
related questions using the functions on
the left hand side of the screen
as there will be a brief question and
answer session at the end of the talk
any unanswered questions during this
session will be answered by dr fagan
following the talk and post it to the
webinar link
so without further ado i would like to
hand over the presenting uh tech uh
capabilities to dr fagan
thank you chad uh and
thank you all for the opportunity to
discuss some of the work that's been
going on in my project
here at the national institute of
standards and technology and thanks for
joining to hear about it so i'm going to
talk to you
today about the analytical ultra
centrifugation of
single wall carbon nanotubes as well as
to give some background information that
you could be applied
to other nanoparticles
before i get started
i just want to make it clear that the
national institute of standards and
technology
does not endorse any specific uh
products
or necessarily methodologies and so even
though i may identify those that does
not
imply
that nist is endorsing
those materials products
etc
also before i start i just want to
acknowledge
that
a lot of this work was done in
conjunction uh with colleagues uh both
in my group and across nist uh and i'm
gonna particularly highlight carlos
silvera batista here who was a postdoc
in my group and did the second
technical or a lot of the work on the
second technical example that i'm going
to show towards the end of the
presentation
so to give an overview as to what i'm
going to talk to you about today i'm
going to give a brief introduction on
analytical ultra centrifugation and what
the technique is and how it's going to
work
i'm going to give
probably the shortest
couple slide overview i can on single
wall carbon nanotubes so that the rest
of the talk makes sense
and then i'm going to
go into the meat of the talk and discuss
what exactly is it that we can
characterize with the analytical ultra
centrifugation technique
what are some of the
problems or pitfalls that we might
encounter
a little bit of discussion as to how
those
pitfalls can differ for different
nanoparticles and then i'm going to give
two technical examples that we've
actually published in my group by using
the analytical ultracentrifugation
measurement technique uh on single wall
carbon nanotubes and so those both of
those technical
notes have been published the first one
in acs nano and 2013 and then the
hydrodynamics measurements
we recently published in langmuir
so what is an analytical centrifuge an
analytical ultracentrifuge is basically
a centrifuge that we can see in while
it's spinning and this is going to allow
us
to actually observe the sedimentation of
the particles as a function of time
and as a function of our applied force
in my lab
we're using the beckmann coulter xli
analytical ultracentrifuge so i have
detection capabilities either using
absorbance
methodology or using the interference
optics system
and the auc works
when you observe
the sedimentation
so i'm just
to step back a second looking up on the
top
half of the slide here in the center
there is a
picture basically of a top-down view of
what the actual experimental cell looks
like for the analytical ultracentrifuge
and you fill one side uniformly for
these measurements with sample the other
side is your reference
and viewing straight through is what
we're going to look at in making our
experiments
as we make our experiments the physical
property
that we're looking at is the
sedimentation rate of the particles
in that sample
so if we have particles that are all of
the same density but in different sizes
basically what we'll see as we'll spin
the centrifuge and observe their
concentration is that the larger
particles will move faster
than the smaller particles
and this difference in their
sedimentation rates is what we're going
to use to characterize those particles
so to do this
to make a measurement we're basically
going to use our optical access to
record the radial absorbance or
interference fringe patterns that we get
with time from the instrument
we're going to assume or at least in my
work i've assumed that those concentrate
that those signals are going to be
directly related to our particle
concentrations and then we're going to
fit that data numerically
with the lamb equation this equation
which is shown the top equation shown
here
is essentially a mass balance on a
sector-shaped slice and a cylindrical
geometry
you'll note that we're ignoring
convection here so this is an important
experimental detail you want to make
sure your sample is not going to conduct
when you spin it up to speed
you just want to have
ideal sedimentation for your particles
if we can assume that our sedimentation
rate and our diffusion isn't going to
vary with our par with the particle
concentration so this is means that
we're in the ideal sedimentation limit
like infinite dilution or essentially
similar then that
equation gets simplified
into this
differential equation on the bottom and
that then can be solved numerically
with various software molecules or
software
programs available
the parameter that we're going to
measure so we're observing what we
believe is concentration the parameter
that we want to get out of this is our
sedimentation coefficient
so
let's see i'll highlight this on the
slide
so the sedimentation coefficient
is going to be
that term that little f that's what we
want to measure
because we can uh
in the ideal limit we can directly
relate this value
of which is
basically the velocity that the particle
sediments normalized by the acceleration
it takes to make that velocity so it's
non-dimensionalized um
and by acceleration we can relate that
value uh to par to properties of either
our dissolved molecules
or our particles our dispersed particles
for all of my work i use this for
formalism
for evaluating the sedimentation
coefficients that we measure because it
is more appropriate
i believe for looking at particles so we
have the sedimentation coefficient is
equal to the volume of the particle
uh multiplied by the density difference
of the particles of the solvent and and
inversely proportional to the
hydrodynamic coefficient
of the molecule which will depend on the
shape and size of your particle
so to show you a little bit of what the
data looks like we're doing
sedimentation velocity experiments in my
lab
almost exclusively and in this case we
fill our
that
analytical centrifugation cell uniformly
with a column height
of liquid that
should be ideally a uniform
concentration and so when you measure
this say with the absorbance signal
which works there or the absorbance
detector which works very well for the
single wall carbon nanotubes
you will get a plateau
and absorbance of a uniform value across
the entire width of the cell but as the
centrifuge starts to spin
as i'll show
first in this animation and then in a
movie
that uniform uh profile starts to shift
outwards in this case because the
particles are sedimenting
and that boundary will broaden uh to a
an extent dependent on your particle
poly dispersity as well as
the diffusion coefficient of the
particle
which is coupled to the particle size
so at this point we're going to
or momentarily we'll show a movie which
is going to show in much greater detail
uh what was just shown in that little
animation
we're only going to show one out of
every five scans taken but this is a
pretty pretty typical data set for a
singly sordid uh nana tube population
which you'll you'll hear about more in a
couple minutes
and
in general you'll see is in this movie a
steeper boundary
indicates that we have a more
monodispersed population or less
diffusion in this case both
and that a broader boundary indicates
you have more
diffusion or significant polydispersity
so if we could show the movie at this
point
okay so
hopefully in that movie you saw that
those concentration profiles
as a function of time
basically the boundary developed on the
left hand side
as in the as we had in the animation
and that
as we went to longer and longer
times of observation the boundary
shifted to the right and that indicated
that all our particles sedimented and
it's actually
the shape of these the shape and the
motion of these concentration profiles
that we can numerically
fit to
extract the sedimentation coefficients
so in this work
we uniformly
extracted our sedimentation coefficients
using the numerical software
said fit that was developed down at nih
and it's available
through
this website link
here that's being shown analytical
ultracentrifugation
so that was a little bit of basics of
the auc
let's talk a little bit about the single
wall carbon nanotubes why we care about
them and what we want to measure
so single wall carbon nanotubes are a
cylindrical allotrope of carbon that but
in this case they're single wall so they
only have a single layer thick shell
an easy way to conceptualize these
molecules is to imagine rolling up a
sheet of chicken wire you can roll up
the sheet of chicken wire and make the
hexagons overlap at many different
diameters and with many different twists
but still get a continuous cylinder
depending on how you roll it up however
you'll get a different diameter of that
cylinder
as well as a different degree of twist
of the hexagonal lattice relative to the
long
axis of the molecule
every single one of these different
diameters and different twists of the
lattice are actually individually are
different chemical species of nanotubes
effectively and each of them has
distinct optical mechanical thermal
electrical and mechanical properties
many of which
we believe will be highly valuable for
multiple applications
but because there's so many of them it
makes a very complex and difficult
evaluation to measure those properties
and that's part of what we're going to
do so there are approximately 300
species of nanotubes not including left
and right-handed enantiomers of many of
the species
but in our case generally we're only
looking at a
a few and synthetic methods will
generally only make 30 to 40 in a given
batch
so
these nanotubes are cylindrical
but they can vary in their aspect ratio
they can be short down to 20 or 30
nanometers or shorter or they can be
very long they can be hundreds or
thousands of nanometers in length
which means that their aspect ratio can
vary from down around 10 to
well over a thousand
this is important for this talk because
although that aspect ratio varies
tremendously um
chemically they're still basically the
same objects
so we need to find a way to deal with
that
a nice thing about the nanotubes with
the cylindrical geometry is that it's
uniform along the the entire length of
the tube
and it's a crystalline lattice so we
know exactly how many carbon atoms there
are per nanometer and that means that
when we look at the nanotubes regardless
of their length they are going to have a
length independent density
which is very important as we get a
little farther in the nanotubes also
have very large are very long
persistence lengths so
these can vary from the small diameter
tubes
from a few microns out to well over 100
microns for larger diameter tubes the
stiffness increases with the diameter
cubed
that's published in this paper that i've
noted here with a little asterisk
and this is basically the length you
need to go to make the two ends of the
nanotube touch
and so those lengths being very long the
nanotubes especially the larger diameter
ones are essentially rods uh entirely
with very little bending smaller
diameter ones will look
will have a little more bend to them
the last important thing um and what i'm
showing on the bottom left-hand photo
here
is that the nanotubes
aren't black as many of them
as many people assume the nanotubes are
can actually be very highly colored uh
because they each have their own
individual optical properties
um
and since those optical properties vary
with the species of nanotubes each
individual nanotube turns out to be a
different color
that's shown
in this
in these photographs on that top hand
row there are different single species
of nanotubes
and in the bottom hand row there are
different diameter range pairs of
semiconducting and metallic nanotubes
the fact that they have these
strong optical properties which lead to
these colors mean that we can readily
detect them
via absorbance optics so i'm going to
mostly use absorbance optics in this
talk
unfortunately when you buy nanotubes
they come as mixtures of solid powders
you don't get those nice pretty
solutions when you buy them off the
shelf from a company so we need to
actually do the work of putting them
into solution and cleaning them up
ourselves
we disperse our nanotubes via sonication
with a dispersant molecule generally in
aqueous solutions for all the work i'm
going to talk about today
the nanotubes were initially dispersed
with sodium deoxycolate which is a
small molecule surfactant there's
actually a chemical structure
on there it's called a bile salt there
are several different variants which
i'll talk about later in the talk
and we sonicate in the presence of this
molecule this molecule will absorb on
the surface of the nanotubes
rendering it
dispersible into the solution
this creates a black liquid which is
shown
in this intermediate step which we then
centrifuge
at a reasonable
gravitational speed to remove most large
aggregates and a lot of the catalyst
and some other garbage
unfortunately at this stage
we still have
other things that are contaminating our
dispersion not just our nanotubes
we also have additional complications
beyond the fact that all these nanotubes
are that there's multiple species of
nanotubes and multiple enantiomers
sometimes of those species
uh depending on the synthetic method
some of the nanotubes can also be empty
so if they have a closed ends on both
end then they will have basically vacuum
inside
but if there's any hole in the graphene
lattice that makes up the nanotube
they'll fill with water and you get
water filled nanotubes
we also have some degree of bundles as
well as
other contaminants stuck to the
nanotubes and some non-nanotube carbon
so we're going to get rid of those
before we make our real measurements
in my project at nist over the years
we've investigated
developed and even discovered
multiple different methods for
processing
these initial dispersions of our
nanotubes
to create
dispersions
of much more highly resolved populations
where we can separate
them by the length of the tube in the
population we can separate out the
individual uh species which we also call
chiralities of the nanotubes for some of
these we can extract enantiomers
although that's a that is still a large
challenge although uh if is impactful
for this work
and we can sort by different
modifications to the structure of the
nanotubes including how defective the
tubes are or whether or not there is
water in the core of the
now sorting the nanotubes is extremely
uh helpful for characterizing them in
the analytical ultracentrifuge and it's
one of the hallmarks of what i'm going
to show
uh
because well for multiple reasons
for one it really helps resolve uh the
signal of the features that you're
trying to look at
it enables measurements on
on things that you specifically know
what they are
we can look at these samples at various
stages of the proc of the processing to
find out
how exactly our processing is affecting
the nanotubes
and when we're done basically we know
exactly what it is we're measuring so
our results are going to have more value
an example of one of the key things
however is shown in the
the two figures here the top figure it
shows the absorbance spectra of that as
sonicated and centrifuged parent
dispersion of the nanotubes with that's
a mixture
and the peaks here reflect
the absorbance by different optical
transitions of the nanotubes
because there's multiple different
nanotubes in there and there's a lot of
gunk these peak transitions are
relatively broad and there's many of
them
in the bottom absorbance trace
you'll notice that the peaks now are
much much stronger relative to
non-specific baseline absorbance and we
have many fewer of them
this allows us this is because we've
sorted the sample for only the six comma
five nanotubes so this highlights a
specific structure of nanotube
with this unique optical property and
allows us to make these measurements at
much higher resolution and at much lower
concentration of the nanotubes
so that was the basic background for
nanotubes what it is that we can measure
um
in the most basic sense with a with the
anal
culture centrifugation we want to
measure the distribution of
sedimentation coefficients
within the population that we're
measuring
for the nanotubes there are a lot of
things that are going to be
you know called
into this
but if we think a very basic level
we could really use this sort of
measurement for quality control
does a preparation method lead to
dispersion that has consistent results
does that distribution
look monomodal bimodal is it really
broad
we could use this
even without analysis to compare
preparations as a function of time
but if we measure other things we can
get a lot more detailed information
one of the methods i'm going to talk
about a lot is to measure the particle
density
particularly of our nanotubes and we're
going to do this by changing the
background solution density
such that the difference between the
particle density and the solution
density changes which should be directly
reflected in the sedimentation
coefficients
and if you measure this at multiple
densities you can basically eliminate
all the unknowns that you don't know
about your particle all the
hydrodynamics come out the volume of the
particles fall out
and you can solve for your particle
density and that will tell us a lot
about our particle
but if you can get even a little more
information if you know your particle
density uh
and your other solution parameters you
can then look at the pop the
sedimentation coefficient distributions
you measure and say uh well what shape
particle would give me this distribution
and if you know
how your hydrodynamics change with your
particle size or shape you can
eventually extract
particle size distributions
one of the things that we really want to
measure particularly for the nanotubes
is the environment
on the nanotube surface so the
environment surrounding a nanoparticle
in general but the single wall carbon
nanotubes in particularly
critically affects
the properties of the nanotube
it affects how it interacts with its
environment it affects its optical
properties it affects uh its transport
properties it affects how um
in applications uh it's going to
interfere interact with say an
environment
in vivo so say you're going to wrap this
with a protein to target it for uptake
by a specific cell
uh if it absorbs new things to its
surface other than that protein it's not
it may not go where you want
so we really would like to know what is
on the surface of banana tube
so that we can do better design and
engineering
i'm just going to show a quick example
here that i'll come back to and revisit
later in the talk
on how
the environment and what you put on the
surface of a nanotube
change
how that changes the properties of the
nanotube
very simply and one property
that nana that specific semiconducting
single wall carbon nanotubes have is
that they will fluoresce and near
infrared
however the intensity of this
fluorescence is extremely dependent on
the degree to which the interfacial
layer on the nanotube surface
screens the nanotube from the broader
environment
on this slide what i'm showing is
data that i've taken on a dispersion of
nanotubes that i dispersed with single
stranded dna and then exchange that
surface that dispersant layer with a
small molecule bile salt
dispersant including the sodium
deoxycoit i talked about earlier but
also two other uh single point mutation
variants of this of the sodium
deoxycolate sodium chole and sodium
torodeoxycola
every all three of these
uh
different variants will displace the dna
from the tube surface and create a
different local environment around the
tube and this leads to the nanotubes
exhibiting
dramatically different
yields of fluorescence for the same uh
excitation and in fact the
if you wrap the tube with sodium
deoxycolate at one percent of the
surfactant you get almost twice the
fluorescence out that you get from the
sodium chlorate wrapped tubes
at the same concentration
so
it's just a simple example
of how the effect of what's on the
surface and knowing exactly what's on
the surface
is important for
driving or determining or engineering
the properties that we want from our
nanotubes
so if we want to think about
what's on the surface of the nanotubes
we should think about what the
geometry actually is
so if i were to draw a picture of the
nanotube in a layer cake model
looking down the long axis of the tube
you get this figure so on this figure in
the very center we're looking straight
down the long axis of banana tube and
then around that nanotube you would pack
a layer of surfactants that would be
distributed in space but mostly centered
around
the nanotube presumably
and then
attached in with that or around it will
be water molecules that are hydrating
that surfactant
out to some radius
and those are the two
two of the things that we really want to
to measure i'm going to highlight them
here on this figure
with some shaded lines to make it much
more easy to see
so i'm going to use a layer cake concept
for how surfactants might or other
molecules might pack on the tube surface
to describe this
the interior of the nanotube here is in
blue so this allows this is whether or
not this is water filled the brown uh
ring here is effectively the nanotube
which we know exactly its crystalline
structure and density of
the red circle is going to be
the minimum volume of surfactant packed
on the outside of the the tube that
we're going to measure
and there's going to be some amount of
water which needs some amount of volume
which leads to this larger outer radius
which is the blue dashed line
so our job now uh
what we're going to do and
what we've been interested in is to
measure our nanotubes in solution uh
with the auc
use uh density contrast measurements to
extract
uh information about the density and
then we want to find out exactly how
thick are these layers and how different
are they between different molecules
lastly though before i get into that
there are a couple things you want to
consider before you jump right in and
make some measurements
so for
for many
nanoparticles you have extended aspect
ratios
very different from
dissolved
molecules that
huddle up and have relatively small
radiuses of
gyration
the concentration effects in terms of
packing and when you go out of the
limits of ideal sedimentation depend on
the particle shape
for
single wall carbon nanotubes there are
rods and so the amount of volume that
they effectively fill goes up with the
radius squared
so even very low concentrations of the
nanotubes you can run out of the ideal
sedimentation range but other
anisotropic particles that are
nanoparticles
will also fall into this category
and so you always want to be careful
that you work at low concentrations
where you're not going to run into
concentration effects
another thing you're going to want to
know before you start
or as we're going you'll see you want to
know what your effective particle is
um you'll see very shortly that you need
to worry about it depending on what your
particle is
as we do the experiment you might need
to worry about
things like hydrogen and deuterium
exchange
due to ph and pd differences
and whether or not you're putting in
buffers where you'll have salts
molecules say that are excluded from
your hydration layer
another thing that's very critical
is knowing what your solution densities
and viscosities are going to be
these are valid are generally available
in tabulated form for many biological
molecules
but as in our case
when we're measuring
surfactant solutions or surfactant
solutions at different concentrations or
with different
background liquids we really you really
have to measure those values
explicitly on the solutions that you're
going to work with
because those values will directly
impact the accuracy of your results
a last thing is
generally absorbance is going to report
absorbance in particular is going to
report a mass average
sedimentation coefficient distribution
and so comparing that
to other techniques such as afm where
you're counting
actually counting particles and gonna
measure a number average
uh that's an important thing to consider
or a light scattering where you
may measure another different sort of
particle size average something you want
to think about before your measurements
start
so on to the actual work now that i've
spent uh
20 minutes here you know running you
through the basics
now we're going to actually measure our
nanotubes and i'm going to start off by
telling you about the density contrast
measurements to measure the interfacial
layers around the surface
of what in this case
is a sample of nanotubes enriched in a
single species
this is going to be the six comma five
species it's a relatively small diameter
nanotube its diameter is under a
nanometer um
by the carbon centered carbon centers
definition
or
just slightly over a nanometer when you
add in the the volume exclusion of that
uh that carbon shell
the sample we're going to look at has
not has been sorted both by only be a
single species but also to be a very
a sort of narrow
length distribution
and both these things are going to make
our data much clearer
so here
again is an optical trace i showed this
earlier but just to point out this is
the actual uh absorbance spectra of the
sample that we're going to measure in
the analytical ultracentrifuge as well
as a picture of of
the sample before dilution to our
working conditions uh in a one
millimeter cuvette showing off the color
that these optical transitions
uh give
to the nanotube solution
as well as well a an afm there that
basically demonstrates the nanotubes are
all approximately
about a micron and a length
so looking at this uh spectra we're
going to measure
the sedimentation of the nanotubes at
we can measure it at various different
wavelengths for this work wipe we
primarily measured
the concentration or measured the
absorbance in the analytical
ultracentrifuge at the two wavelengths
specified by the arrows
we didn't find any difference regardless
of which wavelength we used to measure
the the concentration but these two
specific wavelengths
give us the
uh the strongest
absorbance uh at a given concentration
um
of the nanotubes and so it both
increases our signal to noise strength
as well as allowing us to work at
the
lowest concentrations that we can so
that we have to worry the least about
concentration effects and not being in
the non-ideal range
so let's look at some actual data
that we actually that we measured on the
analog ultra centrifuge
so
at the top of here on this page
are a series of concentration profiles
that i measured on that six comma five
nanotube sample from the last
slide in uh 10 gram per liter sodium
deoxycolite surfactant solution
in water at 20 degrees
celsius
we're only showing every third scan here
but we we took a lot more
uh
data because well why not uh it
certainly allows you to fit
at very high resolution
so if you look at these concentration
scans the first one which starts at the
very left uh basically gives you a flat
plateau all the way across that's
because we uniformly filled the solution
into the cell before spinning it and
then as the
centrifuge is spinning the nanotubes are
sedimenting so the concentration
boundary develops on the left hand side
there and then slowly
moves rightward
with time
even before we fit this data it's clear
from these
concentration curves that we have a
relatively monodispersed sample the
boundary that you see is steep
and apparently singular we don't see any
evidence of multiple rates of
sedimentation
and
the we see a nice generally
uniformly decaying absorbance region in
the plat
absorbent signal in the plateau region
which is due to radial dilution
and meaning that we don't see much or
any back diffusion uh either
so we have these concentration profiles
and as i said before we're going to use
this uh numerical the software
said fit to numerically
fit the distribution of sedimentation
coefficients uh that best describes this
data
and now i'm going to
should come
here we go
show the fit lines that said fit gives
in terms of the concentration profiles
that said it
calculates
on top of the actual measured
experimental data and here is the
distribution of sedimentation
coefficients that reflects
those fit lines
in the
curve
so we have an extremely uh sharp
distribution it's monomotal
and that's good because it's going to
help us resolve
our
the effects on our nanotubes as we make
changes to our background solution
density
so that's our data again what do we want
to measure we want to to measure the
density and sizes of the various layers
surrounding the nanotubes
the first of which we're going to get at
by using a density contrast between
water and deuterium oxide so we're going
to go from h2o to d2o as our background
liquid but we're going to keep our
gram per liter sodium deoxycholate
solution constant concentration constant
the entire time
and as long as the d2o distributes
uniformly throughout the entire volume
of the fluid including the hydration
layer surrounding the nanotube
what it is that we're going to measure
in terms of the density of our particle
is going to be what is called the
anhydrous partial specific volume
so this is going to be
the density of the nanotube plus its
surfactant without any contribution
from the background
water
if you want to learn more about
the measurements of anhydrous partial
specific volumes via density contrast
there's an excellent paper
by brown at all and plus one
in 2011
that you can go and look at
so we want to measure
here let's pull this up
we want to get at the density of the
particle by changing
this
the density of our background media
we're going to do this by water to d2o
and this is again should be directly
proportional to our sedimentation
coefficients
so now on this slide i'm showing the
measured distributions of sedimentation
coefficients for the same 6-5 sample
only changing
the ratio of water to d2o
in the
sample solution
or keeping everything else constant what
the data shows is that as we add more
d2l the average sedimentation
coefficient is becoming monotonically
smaller so in this
i ie the nanotubes are sedimenting more
slowly and so on the figure
the peak is moving leftwards
now part of this is solution viscosity
changes which you have to take into
account and we're going to take those
into account on all the on the future
slides that we show
because the
viscosity of water and d2o is is
different um
but if we assume that the peak of these
sedimentation coefficient distributions
is represented representative of the
same mode of the particle distribution
at
every solution condition
we're going to be able to extrapolate
out to when this mode of the
distribution would go all the way down
to zero with our by changing the
background
density of the liquid and that will be
you would get to zero when the density
of the particle matches the density of
that background liquid
before i do that though i just want to
point out
that doing separations and having as
much disperse of a population as
possible really enables you
to
improve the precision of the
measurements that you're going to do
um
so on this slide i'm comparing
the distributions that i showed on the
back are on the on the past slide
uh first is distributions that were
measured
uh for the same water to d2o uh
comparison for other nanotube public for
other nanotube populations that were
either only sorted by species which is
the top figure or just as prepared which
is the bottom figure now i don't want to
be negative about this data both these
papers were published a long time before
i did
my work and they were really the impetus
for
us doing these measurements
at all
but moving forward i think it's clear
that the more
uh you know about your population
and the more
resolved it is it's the more powerful
auc will be as a tool for enhancing
for measuring these and characterizing
these populations so now we're going to
plot only
the different modes
of that distribution so what the f
values were
that we measured
as has a function of the background
solution density uh correcting the
sedimentation coefficient for the
viscosity
of the
of the different solutions
so this is giving us
so if we plot
those peaks out for different solutions
here varying
from
the
sedimentation velocity
in just water
to the sedimentation velocity
in d2o
and then moving towards we actually want
to make measurements in d2180 because
the nanotubes are are relatively dense
and we wanted points out here closer to
the intercept to improve our precision
you can see
that
as expected
the
difference in the density
of
that that density difference between the
particle and the medium is directly
proportional and
linearly proportional
to the sedimentation coefficient value
and if we fit a line through all these
points
which the points are basically identical
regardless of how we define the mode of
that distribution we can we can measure
an intercept uh which is where the
sedimentation coefficient would go to
zero and that gives us the density of
this specific nanotube species in this
specific solution condition
in this case it's
1574 plus or minus 20 kilograms
per meter cubed
which is the anhydrous density of our
nanotube uh this specific nanotube
however if there are any nanotube
separation folks listening
you'll realize that this density
is very different from the density that
we often think about
when we centrifuge nanotubes which is
the density of the nanotubes that we
observe during
density gradient ultra centrifugation
which is a separation technique uh where
we're trying to separate out different
species of nanotubes based on their
density differences due to their
geometric differences
the reason why we measure
a different density here in this
measurement
is that the water and the d2o are
uniformly exchanged
throughout the entire
volume of the solution including the
hydration volume and that makes the
hydration volume uh effectively have the
same
back the same density as the background
solution which makes it invisible to the
density measurement so in this case
we're only measuring the density of the
nanotube plus its attached surfactant
so what does this anhydrous density tell
us
in the case of sodium deoxycolate we can
independently measure what the density
is of our
surfactant molecule we do this using a
kratky balance technique
and we know exactly what the density is
of our crystalline
constant diameter
carbon shell
lattice if we assume then that the water
inside the nanotube because these are
water-filled nanotubes is reflective of
the outside solution conditions we can
then just do a
mass balance and calculate out what the
minimum volume of surfactant
is required to be attached to the
nanotube to get the density that we
measure
if we use our layer cake model we get
the these geometric sizes on the
left-hand
side
figure here
which i'm going to circle um
where our nanotube core is just a little
over a nanometer across and it's
excluded volume
and then we have then another sort of
nanometer of closely packed
assumed surfactant
on the surface
now this is a minimal radius of the
absorb surfactant
because our density measurement isn't
telling us anything about how the
surfactant is basically distributed
around the nanotube as long as it's
spatially the same and all the solution
conditions in which we measured it uh it
could actually all be out stuck on a
straight line from the nanotube surface
but this seems unlikely
it seems much more likely that it would
sort of be radially uniform in which
case the calculation
based on the size of the sodium
deoxycholate molecule
tells us that we would have roughly
surface coverage
of the nanotube surface by deoxycolate
with four and a half or approximately
molecules of that surfactant per linear
nanotube or linear nanometer down the
axis of
the
nanotube
both these values turn out to be a
little large
for a single layer coverage um
and so it's
because the calculation of that coverage
percent doesn't uh
include steric hindrance between the
surfactants themselves so we probably
have more than a single layer structure
attached here
so that's what we can tell from the
anhydrous measurement
whether
measuring
water versus d2o
and now i mentioned the term effective
particle several times earlier and what
i mean by this is uh well suppose
instead of adding
d2o instead of water i was going to vary
the density of our background solution
by adding a molecule that was excluded
from the hydration layer around the
nanotube in this case the bulk solution
now has a density difference to the
hydration layer as well as to
the
surfactant and the nanotube itself so
now our effective particle instead of
just being the nanotube plus the
surfactant is the nanotube plus the
surfactant plus all of the water
in the region from which
the
density modifying agent
is excluded on average
so this is going to incorporate or
integrate into the density that we're
going to measure all of this volume of
water
along with our
surfactant and nanotube density
so let's make this measurement
we're going to use the molecule iodine
which is what we what is used for
nanotube separations frequently
as our excluded
density contrast modifying molecule
on this slide i'm now showing
the same data points i did before in the
dark blue line
but also adding the measurements that we
make
when
are the results of the measurements when
we add this excluded molecule
to make the density contrast and as
you'll see
the
intercept here
is
at a dramatically lower density
than previously
and that's because we've integrated in
all that water to calculating the out to
in the effective particle to make
the density measurement so what does
this value tell us
this value tells us that if the density
of the water and the hydration layer is
the same as that of the bulk surfactant
solution then the hydrated radius has to
extend
quite a long way from the nanotube
surface
and well beyond where
the minimum anhydrous radius is
this is going to be another point of
comparison for what's on the surface of
the nanotube
and again as the single layer
there's the more than one layer
sort of
shell that we were
thinking about from the anhydrous
measurement this measurement of the
amount of water that has to be attached
to the nanotube to reduce its density by
that much
has to be mathematically quite a bit
and this is also consistent with having
more than a single layer of nanotube
packing
so let's revisit
sort of looking at the differences uh
in the surfactant packing layers as a
function of those
different uh bile salt surfactant
structures that i mentioned earlier
so
earlier i replaced single stranded dna
with one of three
different uh small molecule bile salts
and measured that there were different
fluorescences
in this case
instead i'm going i've i
what we experimentally did was dialyzed
the uh nanotubes from one bile salt
surfactant to another bile salt
surfactant
over very long periods of time to make
sure we had full and complete exchange
and then measure the fluorescence of
each of those resulting samples
so after dialysis the absorbance spectra
of all of our nanotube samples are
exactly the same or within very small
shifts regarding to differences in the
dielectric environment and the peaks of
the fluorescence are only going to shift
slightly but what we find is that the
fluorescence intensity
still changes dramatically depending
upon what our dispersant molecule is
in this case
again we're looking at this fluorescence
and what we find here is that our
deoxycoit and our toro deoxycoit display
uh sand dispersed samples
display effectively identical
intensities of fluorescence whereas the
sodium chlorate dispersed sample
displays much less fluorescence
and we know that this is exactly the
same sample and exactly the same
solutions
and so we want to relate this property
change to that surfactant packing so
let's go and measure how those packings
are different on the various surfactants
by re doing our density contrast
measurements both for the anhydrous
value and for the hydrated value
okay
so here's the plot showing the viscosity
corrected mode sedimentation coefficient
values versus solution density for each
of the three biofelt surfactants all in
the same population magnitude
you'll see immediately that there's
clear
differences
between each of the populations in where
their intercepts are as well as in the
absolute values of their sedimentation
the deoxycolate is these black circles
and so both the sodium chloride and the
sodium toro deoxycolate
samples
are obviously
are both have higher
sedimentation coefficients so they
sediment faster
uh but
this is interesting because both of
their densities at the intercepts are
lesser
so their density difference is lower so
that's an interesting thing their
densities that are actually lower in
terms of the anhydrous density is
interesting and their density of their
hydrated density is higher
so those are three things that you can
pull out and these are related exactly
to the differences and structure
of the bound surfactant layers
on
on the nanotubes
so we can independently measure the
density of the surfactant molecules
then simply calculate out what the
anhydrous shell size has to be as well
as the hydrated
shell size has to be for each of the
three surfaces
i'm going to skip to another the next
slide here where those values have been
tabulated out but i think the more
interesting
part of this slide
is comparing the actual physical sizes
of what those minimum
anhydrous surfactant packing layer size
has to be as well as the what the size
of the hydrated layer has to be uh based
on that just
based mathematically on the density
differences um
on the upper part here
uh
the
density is telling us that there
is more
surfactant in both cases for the sodium
chlorate and sodium torodeoxycolite
in terms of shell size
on in terms of volume of surfactant
stuck onto the nanotube
surface
but particularly
in the sodium choline case the hydrated
shell size
is dramatically smaller
than for the other two surfactants
this is going to a smaller hydrated
shell size we can thus hypothesize
uh is going to allow more penetration of
the environment around the nanotube down
to the nanotube surface and lower the
observed fluorescence that we saw
uh
two slides ago
uh the torah of the oxycoyte in contrast
um
probably
it's a different shaped molecule it
probably is packing in a single layer
which accounts for the densities that we
measured
on and reported tabula easily
whereas the deoxycoin
forms a double layer
now so from our density contrast
measurements we can then say our
deoxycolate
molecule is forming roughly a
one to two layer uh solution shell
around our nanotube uh whereas sodium
chlorate or sodium torah they actually
form basically a single layer around the
nanotube um just with different packing
densities and with different uh
exclusion of water from the nanotube
surface
and these results are consistent with
what people have inferred from various
other measurement techniques but we now
know with
dramatically higher precision
than those other techniques reported and
can make the direct correlation
to our fluorescence or our other optical
properties that change as a function of
those molecules
so that work was all published in
that first paper that i mentioned in acs
nano basically by looking at making
these density contrast measurements on
the nanotubes uh in
walking before we started running and
looking at more difficult problems i'm
going to
relatively quickly now go through the
second example
that we
did
or that we published out of my project
here on looking at the hydrodynamics of
the single wall carbon nanotubes in
solution and this is some of what i
think is beautiful work done by carlos
silvera batista when he was here at nist
so instead of using that 6'5
nanotube sample we used earlier here
carlos used
empty
single wall carbon nanotubes of somewhat
larger diameter
that he first separated out
to isolate only these empty tubes um
and then he took that population and he
length fractionated it using a high
resolution technique called size
exclusion chromatography to generate
multiple length populations of the
nanotubes but with
a uniform diameter distribution and
nanotubes in all populations but
different lengths of the nanotubes
across the populations
to be able to measure hydrodynamics you
need to know what the size distribution
is of your particles so for comparison
to the results we're going to get off of
auc
carlos went and measured thousands of
nanotubes or at least hundreds of
nanotubes
um
for each of these individual length
fractions with uh atomic force
microscopy or afm to be able to tell
measure the length distributions of
those particles
or of the different populations
accurately
these distributions are shown here on
the upper right
and you'll note that the
the scale on the x-axis changes a little
bit
so we have dramatically different length
populations of our nanotubes
now we want to measure the hydrodynamics
of the nanotubes as i mentioned way back
at the beginning of the talk
the sediment we're going to get at these
through the sedimentation coefficient
the sedimentation coefficient is
proportional to the volume of the
particle and proportional to the
identity difference which we use in our
density contrast studies and inversely
proportional to our hydrodynamics
so we want to look at the hydrodynamics
but before we can do that we need to
know what the density of our particles
are so we make sure that we don't
uh
bring in anti-effect of that and we want
to know both the particle density and
what the hydration radius is
for our comparison point
but as we spent
i spent a couple minutes going over we
know exactly how to do this and we
measure our particle density through our
density contrast variation
and for these particular
diameter nanotubes for the empty
nanotubes
we can measure
now our anhydrous density which is the
red line through the red points with an
intercept of
1317 kilograms per meter cubed as its
anhydrous density
and 1060
kilograms per meter cubed as its
hydrated density
you'll notice that the anhydrous density
is quite a bit lower here that's because
the
the empty core of the nanotube is
basically acting like a balloon a
density difference to the water
which vastly reduces its density
and from the density difference between
those two density measurements we can
calculate out that our hydrated diameter
is approximately
seven nanometers
this is this is an important value to
measure
because it's quite likely that if the
hydration layer is fairly smooth then
the radius at which the shear plane is
hydrodynamically
for the nanotube is likely to be pretty
close to
this value of
the hydrated diameter
so it's going to give us a comparison
point when we look at hydrodynamic
models
to compare against and if a hydrodynamic
bottle basically predicts a hydrodynamic
a radial hydrodynamic radius
less than the three and a half
nanometers indicated by this hydration
radius
we can pretty much say it's not well
representing our data because it's not
physically
possible
so what are the sort of models that
people have used for friction
coefficients of extended rod structures
such as single wall carbon nanotubes
and basically there are several
different sets
we chose to compare the effectiveness
of different models
including a low order asymptotic
expansion expression uh uh the barrismo
expression that's commonly used
in the literature
a higher order asymptotic expansion
expression this expression is from
bachelor
and an exact
numerical method calculated expression
that was recently done using the path
integration method zeno
although the details of each of these
hydrodynamic expressions
differ
all three of them
are to first order stating that longer
nanotubes will water it will sediment
logarithmically faster
uh
with respect to their aspect ratio than
shorter nanotubes
so the general trend is all the same can
we tell the difference apart between the
details
so i showed you
the data of measuring
the the background
density difference let's look at the
sedimentation coefficients distributions
that we measure with the length with the
different length fractions of the
nanotubes
so on the far right hand side
of these distributions of sedimentation
coefficients that are shown in the
figure
is the sedimentation of the longest
population that we measure so we see
exactly the trend
that we expect where the longest tubes
sediment the fastest
the uh this is the a4
the and the shorter populations
sediment monotonically less fast than
those longest
populations
now the top data here
shows the sedimentation coefficient
distributions
that we measured
directly as we measured them and
calculated their values for via said fit
unfortunately our separation of the
empty and the water filled nanotubes was
not 100 efficient
and so these structures are bimodal
and so we deconvoluted the contributions
of the of the empty and the water filled
tubes which both have the same length
distribution
from each other so that we only look at
the sedimentation coefficient
distributions of the empty tubes and
that's this deconvoluted data is shown
on this slower figure
the details of which you can look up uh
in the actual paper
so what should we see if we plot the
sedimentation coefficient uh
mode of these distributions versus the
mass average length that we can
calculate from our afm data
so i said that all of the hydrodynamic
theories say that we should see
logarithmically faster sedimentation
as a function of the length of the rod
or as a function of the aspect ratio
which for a constant diameter rod is
essentially with the length of the rod
so we expect to see this red line curve
which is a logarithmic curve
and if i plot the data out on the figure
this is exactly what we see
we looked at two different diameter
distributions of empty nanotubes
as a function of their length and found
find that their sedimentation
coefficient distributions
do
well reflect this
this logarithmic trend in their
sedimentation velocity
as a function of their aspect
to be a little more complex in our
analysis we can do we can
use our hydrodynamic models and
calculate out what the best fit
hydrodynamic radius is
using that
using each of those
models to represent our experimental
data
this is tabulated below
and if we make this comparison between
our radial
hydrodynamic
radius so this is the radius
radially from the nanotube surface where
that foot plane is
versus our mass balance
determined hydro
hydrated
radius
what we find is that the higher order
asymptotic expansion expression as well
as two different numerical models uh the
mansfield douglas exact solution and a
second
numerical model solution
all give values for this radial
hydrodynamic radius
extremely
consistent with the mass balance
calculated
hydrated radius
from the density contrast measurements
but that the simple
uh
the low order asymptotic expansion
expression doesn't nor does a leading
term express expansion expression both
of those give
values for what you would expect the
hydrodynamic radius to be
that are
a physical
with the hydrated radius that we
independently calculated it means that
over the range of aspect ratios that
we're looking at those expressions
do not
well describe the hydrodynamics of our
single law carbon nanotubes
like to point that out because
frequently in the literature people use
these either leading term expansion
expressions or the low order asymptotic
expansion uh
expression because the expressions are
so simple
but basically you're using something
that is going to be adding
that is physically not going to well
describe in the sedimentation of those
single wall carbon
nanotubes but if we look at the higher
order ones
it works out extremely well and the
exact equations almost exactly give the
same i mean
well within the error bars
give almost identical
even nominal values for what the uh
that hydrated and hydration radius
are
so
as i like to say you know 90 plus years
of hydrodynamic theory actually works
and this is actually a great
accomplishment
i want to you know say i was
extremely
proud of the work that carlos did on
this
this is the first demonstration
that
the hydrodynamic theory for a rod works
over an aspect ratio range anywhere near
this
previously it had been done with several
uh
monomoto particles such as tmv
or
very short aspect ratio rods like gold
nanorod sort of things or silicon
nanorods but that could only get up to
aspect ratio of about 20
or
such as the pmv or discrete particles or
ffd virus
here we have the identically
the identical chemical species of
nanotubes
but have an aspect ratio variation from
about uh 40 to several hundred for the
same particle and we verified that the
hydrodynamics worked
so that's really nice to know
but this is only the mode of the
distribution
how does this comparison
of the hydrodynamics
look if we actually look at the entire
distribution shape so we've
independently measured the distribution
of the lengths via that counting
technique atomic force microscopy
and we have our sedimentation
coefficient distributions so let's look
at the
distribution of lengths you would
calculate using the different
hydrodynamic models
from the sedimentation coefficients and
compare them to our afm data
so if we look only at one fraction it's
a this is a fraction
of
length that's right in the middle of our
our distribution that we're looking at
so this was these are nanotubes that are
effectively 250 nanometers long
we find
that
the distribution of lengths which is the
solid line calculated
using a hydrodynamic model from our
sedimentation coefficient data
only will represent only well matches
with our afm counting data
again for the more complex expressions
here with the bachelor expression or the
mansfield
mansfield douglas expression you can see
that
for both of the two diameter populations
shown that the solid line is well
matched up with the histogram which is
the as measured
data from the afm data but those low
order expressions
fail horribly
and accurately representing the data
so if we have
particles that we know uh the density of
and we know which hydrodynamic model
works let's check now that we can
reproduce our length distribution across
the entire range of length distributions
that we're interested in so now
i'm going to use the mansfield douglas
expression use the sedimentation
coefficient distributions from every
single one of those fractions of
different lengths that we measured and
compare them to our afm data and what we
find is that the auc
does a tremendously good job
of measuring sedimentation coefficient
distributions that can be
converted into length distributions of
the nanotubes using the validated
hydrodynamic model
and that nearly identically overlap
with our afm derived histograms
for each of the various length fractions
uh changing by more by almost an order
of magnitude uh in their average length
so this was really i think a tremendous
result and it's the sort of result
that's going to allow us in the future
to use the analytical ultracentrifuge
for
high precision quality control
measurements
and characterization
so that concludes my talk about that uh
technical aspect and i'll just wrap up
quickly because i know i'm over time um
you know and
in summary i hope i've shown that auc is
a viable and powerful method for
characterizing single wall carbon
nanotubes in particular but i think
other nanoparticles in general
the more mono dispersed your sample is
the better your measurements will be in
terms of their precision
but you can always do quality control i
believe
uh understanding your effective particle
is necessary um you know if you're going
to put your particles in and try to
measure them you want to know what your
environment is doing
in terms of what your effective particle
will be to analyze your result
um
and this is really at the cutting edge
of nanoscience
so with that um
i think i'll skip this where we're we're
going uh slide uh maybe not we have
better separations we'll go into more
advanced experiments to look at smaller
differences through the auc and we'll
use these densities that we measure to
provide a basis to fundamentally
do comparisons with molecular simulation
studies
i hope that you'll follow along with
these results
as we complete them and are published
and so i want to thank
the organizers of this webinar for again
for a while for giving me the
opportunity to tell you about my work
and again my colleagues uh
many who are
all been wonderful colleagues uh
and did a lot of the action a lot of
this work and i want to acknowledge
their contributions and with that i'll
stop and thank you for your time and
i'll take your questions
thank you dr fagan very interesting talk
it's fantastic that the analytical
ultracentrifuge can validate not only 90
years worth of work but also
other complementary technologies such as
afm
at this time i would like to point
everybody to the blue q a um
uh button on the left hand side of your
screen uh we're still taking questions
um for dr fagan to answer
in the meantime there were a couple that
came in already
one question
asked
if concentration has such an important
effect on carbon nanotube sedimentation
and behavior
wouldn't the concentration become
a problem as the carbon nanotubes are
packed closer during the centrifugation
process
i think this is related to uh
aggregation of carbon nanotubes as they
are centrifuging can you provide some
insights dr fagan
uh
yes so that i mean that's that's a good
question um
in a large extent uh these
banana tubes that we're looking at
are
are large uh compared to what was maybe
a biological molecule that many people
are are familiar with for the technique
and that makes
um
their diffusion basically meaningless
relative to their ballistic
sedimentation
from the
uh
the applied
acceleration
this means that there's really no back
diffusion off of the bottom boundary of
the cell
and so there's no increase in
concentration that penetrates back into
the volume that we're measuring
from that back diffusion so actually
we start the
uniform concentration at the beginning
is the highest concentration that the
nanotubes experience
during the entire experiment because as
they sediment they're moving
in these experiments they're sedimenting
they're moving towards the bottom then
the shell is the cell is sector shaped
so it is expanding
with the radius
along
as you move out from the center of
rotation and so the nanotubes are
actually
undergoing radial dilution as they move
outwards because that sector
the slice of volume is increasing
um
uh
as you go farther in radius from the
center of rotation so
as long as the concentration at the
beginning is not a problem
um
it's not a con it's not a prob it
doesn't develop to be a problem at least
with nanotubes over maybe 30 or 40
nanometers where they're effectively
become non-diffusive
right thank you for that
no other questions have came in so i'll
ask one myself um
what is your separation range uh are you
able to resolve um carbon nanotubes on
the angstrom level using the auc
uh
in terms of their diameter uh
yes uh
the
the density differences that we're
measuring
um and that we
in the auc and that we exploit uh in a
preparative centrifuge by putting a
density gradient medium in
that uh
allows you to spatially resolve
uh those different buoyant density
nanotubes based on their structures
uh the different nanotube structures can
be
effectively down to like .01 angstroms
in different from each other so on the
in terms of diameter
yes you can resolve uh those
differences in density
um we haven't yet
done that that's probably
uh the limits of the precision
of the instrument the way we've been
doing the experiment are probably not
quite that high
uh in the characterization side yet but
are close uh in terms of length
uh i think you know we still
uh
i it's the fitting is
i think very impressive
but certainly uh we're not getting down
to angstrom resolution
um i i think that
the
the nanometer uh tens of nanometers
scale in comparison if we're down to i
we're probably at about a 15 percent uh
error bar
on those averages
by the
our populations are varying by a factor
of
10 to 100 in length so a factor of
15 off the average is still i would say
very good
great thank you a very powerful
technique with that i'd like to conclude
the beckman culture webinar series and
again thank our speaker dr jeffrey fagan
for giving us this talk
you